نستمع الان الى تسجيل صوتي من الصحفي انس
الشريف رصد اصوات اشتباكات عنيفه بالقرب
من محيط مستشفى كمال عدوان وصلنا الان هذا
التسجيل الصوتي في ظل الصعوبه في التواصل
جراء القطع الكامل للشبكه العنكبوتيه في
قطاع غزه نستمع لهذا
التسجيل منذ صباح هذا اليوم القصف لم
يتوقف على شمال القطاع ولكن بالتحديد في
محيط مستشفى كمال عدوان ومشروع بيت لاهيا
وبيت لاهيا ايضا ومخيم جباليا وجباليا
القصف حتى اللحظه مستمر بشكل متواصل في
محيط مستشفى كمال عدوان لم يتوقف نهائيا
الشرايا ما زالت تتساقط على المستشفى هناك
اضرار في المستشفى جراء القصف العنيف في
محيط المستشفى ايضا الشظايا تتساقط على
النازحين في داخل المستشفى نسمع الان قصف
في المكان الان حزام ناري بجانب المستشفى
كما نسمع الان اضرار في المكان الان قصف
عنيف الان بجانب مستشفى كمال عدوان حزام
ناري حزام ناري وكثيف بجانب المستشفى هناك
صعوبه في ارسال الصوره وفي التواصل ايضا
بسبب انقطاع الاتصال وانقطاع الانترنت
هناك كثافه في القصف على محيط مستشفى كمال
عدوان الامر الان صعب جدا صعب جدا هناك
حاله من الرعب والخوف عند الجرحى والمرضى
والنازحين في المستشفى ايضا هنا داخل
المستشفى الاف النازحين مازالوا في
المكان منذ صباح هذا اليوم والقصف لم
يتوقف على شمال القطاع ولكن بالتحديد في
محيط مستشفى كمال عدوان ومشروع بيت لاهيا
وبيت لاهيا ايضا ومخيم جباليه